what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation it's time to get jacked up
as you reach for that like button
because guess what we are watching
Reacher episode 5 today and a fun
question for our audience which
chemistry do you prefer the one with
Reacher and Rosco or Reacher and Dixon
leave it in the comments hit women
against each
other fight fight it out John are you
excited so excited G I'm ready to Swan
Dive into this episode that's what I
like to hear my friend also subscribe
and click that notification to the noi
when our reaction for the episode and
the new year is up also thank you to
prepper for helping us setting down
these highlights you sexy people you
people also thank you to all who have
joined us at our patreon page helping us
to have a massively successful lucrative
Year my God we have bought five houses
thanks to our patrons and now you can
help us buy a sixth when you check us
out on patreon becoming a super sexy
reject so we get the full length ratch
and watchalong where you sync up with
your own copy of Reacher John and I also
cover several things exclusive there
with highlights and watch alongs
included John are you ready to get
jacked up I'm reaching for a pun that
means yes I am that's what I like to
hear
Snowman hey a very special holiday
episode of Reacher Jack reach
Frost I'll give it to you I'll give it
you oh oh [__] wow boy panda pal Lindsay
the monkey they're all packed grab the
burner phone no contact with anyone not
your parents and definitely not your
sister she puts everything on Facebook
she's a pain in the ass that sister 1 to
10 how bad is this I'm not going to come
after you we're just playing a safe
belts and suspenders belts and
suspenders for you guys four how about
you oh we're dealing with some pretty
bad guys you got the big guy we'll be
fine he'll be over in a couple of days
promise the kids I think have this
covered this could be your life Jack
this yeah you could have this with Dixon
a stressed out wife someone asked me
back in the day where I thought you'd
wind up I'd have predicted a slow death
from garia and a half dozen girlfriends
fighting over an 04
Miata that's my life it's my Miata NE
and Dixon just got to the Denver plant
maybe they get a hold of those missiles
and your family won't have to be gone
long you know I learned about this
odonald guy throughout this whole show
he was a bachelor a player but he
settled down that's why I don't trust
him G it's a
Roose okay try hit and reach her like
that break that kid's bones Jack yeah
the dcma was here a month ago yeah now
we're back we're the cold source of
government oversight now we if you
please your foran that's a really cool
center frame act like you're supposed to
be there and carry a clipboard dud I I
get more
clipboards whoa interesting cut
infiltrate so many places never seen a
cut like that it goes from Center to
like diagonal down right you never wore
heels nope not even do a school dance
never went one when I wasn't studying or
taking care of my dad I have to work
what about when you were a hooker yeah
nobody told me about this wouldn't be a
surprised inspection if we called the
head that's how we have a hard time
finding out what's going on with
chocolate because they often get a heads
up that there's going to be an
inspection there so they can hide the
child labor at Little Wing shoulder
fired launchers and missiles order and
delivery schedules 10 minutes ago that's
the delivery schedule the whole lot just
went out the door all 650 of them
650 that's the number the number if
someone had called me first damn I'd
held them for you should have
anticipated the
this Colorado is beautiful it really
looks like this guys
yeah now Jack's going to flip the truck
over an Asian guy he must be a stunt man
they
hired yes there will be a martial arts
sequence any minute
now you need an extra set of hands what
I need is your
truck yeah buddy now cut off his hands
and take them with
you
oh man that's mean that truck was being
so nice too whoa yeah he just stopped to
help them and everything they relied on
the willingness of a truck driver who is
going to stop and be like you need an
extra hand yeah the Brotherhood of truck
drivers whoa weapons of mass destruction
GPS tracker did the job your Associates
a new age came through they might be
upset I killed the driver though
they won't care as long as they get paid
never underestimate the power of greed
greed is good switch the trailers and
get on the road meet you in New York all
this traveling from Denver to New York
so the Aron mikos we were chasing down
in Denver that was mmud yeah we've been
calling him am never been caught no
photos I'm not even sure what
nationality he is just take a guess but
the little bit we know of him he can
supposedly pass for Central American
Italian Greek Middle Eastern he's a
ghost those are what people often think
I am hey hey you could be am first
popped up on our radar 6 years ago
terrorist cell caught trying to acquire
tanks of experimental nerve gas we
scooped up the whole lot all of them
except Mahmud yeah this buy was supposed
to happen with bear bonds the US
Treasury stopped issuing those in the
80s some countries still use them uhoh
someone as cautious as am would use bear
bonds if issued in large enough amounts
you can carry an untraceable fortune in
a briefcase 65 Million worth got get
some you hold a bear bondus like
carrying a million doll Bill the bearer
owns it so no way am lets anyone deliver
payment but him that's where he's
vulnerable just like your brother oh way
to make him uncomfortable back when we
worked the case I asked Joe some
questions of the financial side of
things said the same thing you just did
am will be the delivery boy okay sad
Jack C so fast Sad Sack Jack Sad Sack
Creer I passed the mantle on to you
thank you killing these puns man am and
everyone working with him will be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law bring me the Arctic Monkeys un must
we kill them all
firsto you're in a government office dog
love how they were like oh what do we
say to
[Music]
that
o lot of these Center framing shots are
so well done it's a lot of Center
Framing and lower diagonal good symmetry
18 wheelers can't go that fast on these
roads a decent shot at catching them
yeah especially if they come to a stop
uh bo be careful
neon yes neelon dixley the guys who are
going to tell us the truck broke down
and they had to call another one to come
pick up the trailer but no way a second
truck got here before us nope nope nope
this is
hijacking this may potentially sound
racist but I feel like this ASI guy is
going to do some crazy martial
arts let's find
out
just do one roundhouse kick bring out
your nunchucks I'm Asian guys I could
say it I take it
back oh there's like that ominous snow
Thriller vibe to this like the Snowman
with Michael fast Bender yeah but with
Jack it's
cool the steam from the car Blends in
with the fog of the snow and their hot
breath breath on the cold
wind we really messed this car
up they're in the trunk they are in the
trun
D yeah you'd have access inside look how
scared this guy
is he knows you don't mess with the
one1 oh [__] oh damn goly damn you
ladies are hot they got them all over
got in the butt I'll call the cops
Anonymous do we favor grabb the Manifest
we need the license play it off of bit
it's not a private road well a new age
truck with all 650 missiles in it was
hijacked ow it looks like Swan's still
working for new age according to the
bill of lading Swan personally signed
off on the shipment before he left the
factory Swan what are you doing it's a
digital thumbprint then they forced him
new age New York has Iris scanners on
the doors Thum print locks on the
computers there's no way that anyone
could force Tony Swan through that Maze
of Biometrics without causing a huge
seat new age New York New Age New York
New Age New York the only way that
wouldn't worry about a Ruckus is if all
thousand plus employees were in on this
thing and the OD of a conspiracy that
vast or minimal believe all conspiracy
theories I know you want to believe
Swan's clean boss we all do but things
look the way they look you messed up
Jack if you never recruited him and you
if you didn't make a terrible judge of
character you wouldn't be in this
position right now Way It Go Jack this
is your fault I Blame You Jack all on
you man and his Hendrick's
taste
[Music]
going for a walk he seems so sad this
episode no D Jack more like Jack Griefer
oh
gee see I knew there was a reason I
three to four weeks ago good how' you
like to be jamed into a fox what is a
giant mother we'll be whatever price
you're paying now our supplier can get
you all the eight you can move from an
overseas Source it's in no position to
negotiate terms I do H and
pump in that
order it's pure
Kool-Aid okay the alkaline level on the
H is great bust them lean on them they
give up their Source we bust them then
we all get bumed more fruit s in our
chest more dollar signs on our paychecks
bro give me that fruit salad why would
they add dollar signs it's more paycheck
shut up frony kids cut a point mod well
you only need $1 son yeah breed is a
theme yeah which one of y'all is taking
payments
[Music]
door Dash guys in on it that 105 sounds
like you're was my time damn dude you
have another brick as pure as that for
105 seem better [__] I got a list of
other buyers Swan I came to you I know
you uhoh no idea I know we've met before
what can you do for me 100 take it or
leave it O Come got it you're the guy I
sold my guitar to a while back what no
you got me mixed up with somebody else
Craigslist dude you bought my acoustic I
recognize your username we going to eat
and discuss old times or we going to
make a deal you [__] don't want this
stuff we got other places we can sell it
shoot this guy he plays guitar yeah
we're all keyboardists here wait a
minute when this guy bought it he was in
an army cop uniform oh God here it is
well that's a setback setback
Reacher oh my god wow my God that
thrust
woo oh that's why he trusts him because
Swan took a bullet for him bullet miss
your heart but shatter my collar bone
not going to be playing that guitar for
a while every
cloud hey who don't you mess with the
teamsters no the also them 110 he's
losing blood it's 110 special
investigators what's the 110 the same
thing they're the oneth and they're the
special investigator keep all this in
the reaction prepper yeah I mean it let
me pull up the Wikipedia on the 110th
here the senator has a proposition for
you get in no because he didn't ask
nicely heart what's a magic word Jack
pleaser please get in the
vehicle damn it really does work when
you say please the Little Wing chips
will be ready to install on the missiles
by the time you get here and Mr Swan's
Associates will be taken care of their
plan's already in motion excellent put
my best people on it
kingck is a rert Patrick kind of look
like a evil
baby he does now yeah right his face
he's got like a baby evil baby face
assume you use this location cuz it's
one of the few spots in DC where you can
meet without prying eyes or surveillance
bugs MH it's why I got myself appointed
to the zoos
board imagine Boyd's embarrassment when
he he learned that the people he
revealed our secrets to weren't FBI
agents in the first place of course
security videos showed you entering the
precinct and facial recognition software
matched you to a military ID God damn AI
seems like after you retired you kind of
fell off the face of the earth except
for this incident a couple years ago in
Mar grave Georgia Mar grave I know it
was you and margrave Mr rer I want you
to do the same thing for the situation
we have here o the mil military and
civilian aircraft could be in danger due
to little wi now I can only assume that
means the terrorists are interested in
the attack working hard to obtain it who
do you trust we learned that your old
units back
together don't look so shocked Mr reer
I'm us Congressman I get things done I'm
shocked because a US Congressman got
everything done yep yep it's truly a
work of fiction this Show's political
now people who want this Weaponry can
never be allowed to have it because if
anyone knew you were involved in the
Shady dealings that created Little Wing
in the first place you'd be indicted
give rid the bad guys keep my hands
clean Washington we call that a win-win
two birds one Reacher I did what I did
to give our side the tools they need to
defend democracy I just avoided the
typical red tape that does nothing but
cause the delays that cost lives this
guy's a pain in the ass I don't want
innocent people to die because of it I'm
a political animal I'm not a monster Mr
eer we're in a zoo oh they're in the
political sub cont and the meanings and
the themes and this you like to upset
the apple cart I'm prepared to give you
whatever you need to Aid you in that
endeavor and when you're done no one
will be able to prove that you were ever
near those apples in the first place woo
get all the resources of the reptile
house on your disposal then you can
disappear again no one will go looking
for you or your friends but does he want
to be alone but if no one's looking for
me how will I know I'm real I mean seems
like a reasonably good offer or an
reasonably good cover coroner finally
released Cron's body funeral's tomorrow
whoa we got to go back to New York all
right shootout oh yeah also have a
shootout at the funeral how cool would
that be yeah I've always wanted to be at
a shootout at a funeral mhm jump onto
the coffin you know use it as cover yeah
you have any leads as to where the real
misses went Colorado State Police found
the truck in a field outside Denver it's
empty based on the tracks in the dirt
they think a private plane flew the
weapons out overnight Wow since 11
they've kept a pretty close watch on New
York's skies I were him I fly him into
some small air in Pennsylvania maybe New
Hampshire then drive the weapons into
New York to load them up with little
wing software are U am I love how
they're at this funeral and they're
doing nothing to reflect on just talking
about the
cas that's what you do at cinematic
funerals reer seeing this [__] I'm sorry
for your
loss rest rest in peace all right my
nephews have the same one a it's a great
toy we play with it all the time when I
was a kid I had Aquaman hey I thought it
was so cool how he could talk to
fish too bad it's going to flop I want
you to have this too hey s Jerome he's
the patron s of kids whose moms and dads
go to heaven s Jerome I don't ever want
to be alone want you to say the forever
every night and I'll hope keep you that
close damn this gu friends with the kid
the dead I don't know he's like looking
after this kid awfully close maybe it's
just because he's invested in the case
you know why are you giving toys to my
dead friend
son cozy up to the kid score points with
Mom you see a grieving Widow and think
easy target are you kidding me right now
why' a biker gang take a run at me in
Boston last night cuz you're an [__]
or maybe it's cuz you're the only person
I told we were going there ass Reacher
you know why I was talking to Mikey I
know what it is to look out the window
every night and pray that the next set
of headlights coming down the street is
your father's car even though you know
it'll never happen yep and I was talking
about you not your father I'm talking
about it my father was a cop a good one
and he refused to be on the take and
they killed him for it damn dude guys
you're causing a scene will you call me
dirty one more time and I don't care if
we're standing in front of the Statue of
the holy mother I will give you that
beating that I owe you right here I'll
take that fight anytime you want and two
I didn't know that about your
father I was running those security
names from new age or former NYPD or
from the third precin whoa boss Langston
and a few other guys they were on
Investigation by IIA they took early
retirement and the charges went away
then they all got cushy jobs at New Age
and they hired all their P they on the
take take you need work with this whole
team of bad cops everybody except your
buddy Swan but he's the only one that
has military experience to know what
type of weapons terrorists want so oh
all cops all bad all from the same
Precinct you interview any of them
Gooden you turned their office into a
drive-thru they went to the
ground Swan's like a son yeah he's so
defensive for him stand
by very graceful sequence ready a fire
oh little
guy oh get down whoa whoa what the damn
how' you spot him shoot it at the
funeral yes we got it we got
it oo
o the Tombstones do make for great
cover oh this is a really cool scene
yeah buddy good way for the cops can't
let let them get away as soon as they
hear sirens they scatter I'll draw their
fire you take them out negative we can
do this take your clothes off
rer oh yeah Jack is like the guy in
every video game who's like huge and
slow but has like all
the
this the guy with all the strength and
guns good cinematic
music whoa come on Jack
they must have shot this at a real
graveyard ceter absolutely every one of
the people buried here is an actor so
they would have wanted
this I want to buy a
BMW hey all Let's go Team Up you shoot
at a funeral
AET I saw you protect Angel and Mikey so
I guess you're playing a square you got
a rat in your house still that's for
sure no no time for this guys you both
got a rat R to deal with get this
terrified sniper
yeah pedal on the right let me do my
[Music]
job how just never gets along with lead
detectives I know you climb out of my
ass ass Reacher this is all really well
done intense sweeping high speed Pursuit
jeez
dude I would not be able to concentrate
with you as a
passenger uh Jack seat driver dad not
bad at all not bad at all sneaky
sneaky oh
yeah don't shoot I'm done okay I'm done
sh in the legs at least you're under
arrest [__] these guys took a run at
us in broad daylight at a crowded
funeral means this thing's coming to a
head fast yeah he lawyers up and doesn't
talk until it's too late in a ter has
650 chances to take down a commercial
airliner so what do you want me to do
play a little dirty look the other way
oh dude no oh my God by not telling me
everything you know you're protecting
the people who killed my friends I'm not
going to waste my time with enhanced
interrogation techniques I'm just going
to squeeze the life out of you so if it
any best
reaction Langston wouldn't give you all
the cash up front where you supposed to
meet him to get the rest of the money an
abandoned building is some shitty
neighborhood and queens give it the
address oh
but I don't know any Langston and who
hired you I'm SW guy called
Swan
no jaon and odonnell are in position
Russo's down the street all Lexus are
covered Swan's going to put a bullet in
raer Richer's going to be like Swan's in
a city he's he's being leveraged by
somebody he's been forced to do this
he's brainwashed we'll cut you loose you
get to keep the cash understood yeah man
whatever keep this in your pocket so we
can listen in you try anything we come
in hot and you die with the rest of
them get going
stupid keep it simple stupid he's K so
goddamn aggressive I love it you idiot
somean went to work for new age it's all
a chance to make the kind of money he
always dreamed of and took it he was
hanging out with franzy and being in the
same city and all slipped and said
something that made France supicious
oh boy try to get France in on it figure
with a wife and kid he'd need the money
too this building GNA blow up I think it
probably is if Swan's really in that
building I'm gonna do the same thing I
did to that guy wrap my hand around his
neck and squeeze the truth out of him
swan song
hello
anyone I completed the
job boy oh boy oh boy Swan just going to
be standing in the middle of it all yeah
just stare bearing down re Sunshine
villain now warped Freddy Krueger
guy
o God what a note to end on too I don't
know this Swan guy but it's about to be
his Swan's song Oh yes sir you know what
I'm saying I do know what you're saying
this is the end of swan you're about to
be gone
Swan your time is dawn dark is a [__]
you did it you did it it's okay it's
okay I'm here for you yeah that's what I
want wanted you to be there for me I
didn't want to say it myself I'm your
neie me and my
Cal anyway yeah I really like this
episode uh it was a really good one per
they're setting up the personal Stakes
we were o Donal and his family so that
way we saw that there's something to
lose for odonnell at the beginning here
that if you were to die I I do think one
of them has they're still they're still
pretty much a team of Avengers and I
think we need to get one of them
severely injured on the brink of death
okay I do think we need to get there
however I still thought this episode was
fun engaging I'm really into the whole
it's weird like we don't really see Swan
like only in flashbacks yeah and because
we see how much it affects
Jack it makes me really want that conf I
I'm I'm craving that confrontation
definitely I really want that and the
show is doing a great job at pulling
that out of me like oh I'm seeding for
that man I'm craving it I'm craving I'm
like at a buffet and I'm like what do I
want all I see is this swan dish that I
want and it's that that I don't care
about
the potatoes this metaphor is going
terribly guys it's like when you're at
the when they wrap your food food up and
they make the swan out of it with the
foil yeah we need to move on from the
swan metaphor Swan metaphors done check
check and um the and the and you know
like a reminder of how like all of
Reacher's family is gone and like this
is essentially his last living family
yeah you know so he'll do whatever he
can to protect them and that's why this
is so personal for him so that that that
uh the real showdown at the funeral to
me in a lot of ways because I'm deep as
[__] is the confrontation between him
and bald New York cop car Russo I think
his name Russo yeah uh when they're when
they're arguing with each other I love
them together yeah they have a great
back and forth because it does remind
you a little bit of um black Boston cop
Finley yeah yeah not white Southern Girl
blond
cop uh yeah yes uh uh oh goodness I know
her name uh John I've known all their
names and you can't pull this one I've
known all their names oh it'll I've been
setting you having a blank come on John
uh okay Finlay and uh
Rosco there you go yeah yeah anyway you
put me on the spot and then my brain
cleared out oh no yeah so uh still no
Cameo from her no no at the very endend
she'll come back pregnant with reach
yeah we're starting a team a family a
family Reacher yes oh I love it oh my
God uh but the yeah that that whole
funeral scene I thought was uh really
strong the way they paid the military
tribute seemed very well orchestrated
and then to go like I just thought it
was a really solid sequence of showing
up at the funeral them deliberating over
you know what do they what what is the
next plan of action here what could
really be going down you know Reacher
dialogue and then uh the confrontation
with the cop after he's confronting then
it was a great way to pull out some
personal stuff with the characters that
moment saying goodbye solemnly then
leading to a great shootout that kind of
reminds me of like a seet from way of
the gun leading to a cool car chase to
an epic like the last like 15 to 20
minutes of this I thought was just
perfectly executed yeah I thought it was
really really really well executed um it
was like a strong action political
thriller show
uh in that moment and just seeing how
Reacher is just getting pushed to the
brink of like his his uh he's becoming
so impatient and uh I love it I love it
and because he has to keep agitated he
just has to keep that suit on in the
whole time that same smelly stinky suit
Colorado New York funeral CH way more
once he takes the suit off it's cutting
off the circulation to his head realiz
it's just he just needs a change of
clothes yeah of course anyway John what
do you think of Robert Patrick's role oh
he's great man the boss baby is
killing uh I I I mean you know Robert
Patrick is so far in this show he's he's
mainly he's on the phone the presence of
Robert Patrick being on the phone
swearing at people I like him and I'm
excited for the eventual Showdown or
whatever confrontation comes with him
but for it's you know like watching the
especially the past couple of episodes
have been really nice because uh as I
was hoping the season has grown and I
have gotten more and more tuned to what
it's doing this time around I really
like all that stuff and uh and Robert
Patrick is maybe the one element that
still feels a bit detached from the
Flesh of everything else uh because when
he shows up it does seem like we're
mainly just having Robert Patrick show
up and and be intense but also I get the
sense and stressed intense and stressed
and I get the sense that and not in a
not to like slight the performance of
the writing but like in context of the
story I get the sense that this is going
to be a guy who probably ain't [__] at
the end of the day and is probably going
to go down pretty easy uh so I'm curious
to see how they build his
formidability by the end of the season
because it seems like am is the guy on
that side of things who's like the real
threat and now we have Swan at least
looking to be pretty dang guilty in all
of this and hey maybe they'll still pull
a Twist on us where it's like oh man I
had to go so deep under cover and I had
to let so many things happen not to blow
my cover you know there's all sorts of
stuff uh I know because I have been an
undercover cop for many years of course
you know you got to let certain things
play out you can't just bust in
immediately and start taking people down
because they're bigger fish I know
you've been in unrecovered cop for blind
wave this entire time that's right man
people ask me if I am that guy I am that
guy he is that guy for blind W he is
that othery
wh anyway uh yeah I've been very much uh
just yeah the the mve mood of this
really gripped me and like you said the
snow and the air and that feeling of
yeah like an insomnia or one of those
like snow-based uh this was the most
atmospheric episode absolutely I think
out of every EP this all that's all I've
been craving I've haven't been craving
like the Southern Gothic grit of season
1 I've just been wanting a specific
flavor and I think I think this episode
really provided that like oh you really
feel the cold yeah you really and as
it's getting colder for them physically
the emotional turmoil is also withering
away throughout them yeah and you feel
like the the reer gets colder Jack gets
colder he's going to need a jacket to
warm down how cold he's get yeah he's
going to need one of those fleece
jackets Jack Reacher the Sheep uh yeah
the the wool kind of call you know you
know what I mean yeah Lion's man that's
exactly it he's going to skin a lion
where it's man he's going to go back
crav the hunter by the end of this yeah
craving the reacher uh I like that scene
when they go into the gorilla house or
whatever that was and they have the
meeting with the politician guy and he
fun fact is a deleted scene where he
fought a gorilla oh or did Allen richson
just pick a fight with a gorilla and if
no both it might have I think they tried
using it as footage but then they real
keep rolling on this don't don't stop
rolling on I think he's winning I
think I think this gorilla is about to
go extinct okay Alan Rich's now he he's
on all fours and he's he's crawling into
the cave and he's claiming dominance
over the rest of the girl he's beating
his chest and he's making all these
strange noises and all the gorillas are
gathering around him thinks he's a
gorilla who's going to pull Alan out of
there does anybody speak sign
language what do we got Alan has
officially murdered our
ad
yeah he directs the show now just tells
people where to point the camera and
everybody else just yes sir Mr Jack Mr
Mr Rich whatever you want me to call you
it's fine no eye
contact I would pay good money for I
would pay good money to watch a gorilla
versus Alan mer to watch him reain
dominion over a not just gorillas but
gorillas in a zoo yeah watch him lift a
gorilla above his head before he drops
it down on his knee Bane
style your spirit or your body just an a
loin cloth living at the
zoo yes a loin cloth he would look good
he would look really good in a Lo Club
he would man so we need someone from IGN
just be like would you play Jesus and be
like I would be interested and then bam
we get a whole bunch of Articles and
headlines alen richon interested in
playing Jesus and we get all that fan
art of him in a loin cloth yeah I think
it look good and him with like the long
hair too yeah but still just as buff as
he is right now I mean you got to get a
different interpretation we've seen all
kinds of Jesus rules he's got that buff
where you have to just turn your whole
body to look at people why wouldn't you
listen to him like how does guy gets so
buff and zero BC you
know that's a good
question I don't know you're the
bodybuilder Among Us how and I know how
to achieve that that physique even with
all the modern gym technology we have
today I definitely know how to achieve
that you know just eat a 100 chickens a
day never stop benching never stop never
stop benching anyway uh yeah uh am what
do you think about am isn't he great he
was here for a minute yeah we saw him
for we got so many villains yeah we do
we need a female villain that way the
women have someone to fight yeah well
there was that one lady from the um New
Age company but they already raided her
house know she was kind of like an
annoying you know you need look if when
you have the big finale at the end it's
the women fight the women that's the
that's why you have a bad woman get get
at least like an evil female henchman
yeah for for Robert P like evil female
henchman assistant who happens to be
great at martial arts yeah and who never
speaks and who has some kind of
eccentric weapon oh yeah yeah yeah and
then like Neely can fight her yeah
exactly and then that' be great right
yeah and then Dixon joins in and they
both take her down yeah then it's a
message about
girl women working together drive that
home yeah yeah dude that's how you how
you that's how you infuse Progressive
feminism into your show which is what
I'm all about especially when I show
forck Reacher man oh yeah you know Jack
Reacher is a feminist look at the team
he assembled there were intersectional
there were women on the team people
various ethnicities yeah people color
not very many old people or disabled
people but you know it's the Army and so
you know what can you do unfortunately
but with what he's given Jack is a
pretty enlightened cat yeah oh totally
based based Reacher
um
anyway
am was great I love am was great man him
on the phone just Jack and Russo is my
favorite thing like I I I I I love the
team together but uh the moment with
Russo and the kid and and the Widow I
thought was great and him and Jack and
and and even though especially
throughout the Chase and everything
they're so Odd Couple Jack is constantly
busting his chops like when they get to
that moment and after everything made
about like I'm not dirty you know that
that that moment of convincing where
Jack is like look they're getting
desperate and following the book is
going to hurt this investigation in the
long run like that was a pretty
compelling beat oh sure and the way they
played that in the acting and and the
framing I thought was nice just him
being like okay turn turn the cheek cuz
I trust you you know and I trust that
this is for a good reason and that whole
thing with his dad his dad wouldn't take
any bribes so he got whacked you know
like yeah I mean and Jack and Rose so
they honor their legacies they do they
respect where they come from
Legacy no
notes perfect cut print anyway um say
John
yeah one thing that I do feel is getting
kind of lost here uh-huh
huh it seemed like when they got to
episode two they were like Dixon
Reacher and then they've like had a
couple of conversations and unless
there's like a direct interaction I
don't feel like it's something that's in
the air between
them okay sexual attention or nor
chemistry nor romance that idea of like
when you get into like a life and death
situation they're not thinking about oh
I got to get back to Reacher oh I got to
get back to Dixon it's sort of just like
whenever there I'm really not sure what
it is with
them yeah it feels like a thing that
could happen but isn't
necessarily it doesn't have that like
propulsively see portrayed that you can
just be casual friends with benefits I'm
waiting to see what the payoff is of
that because uh when they're when
they're at the funeral and stuff there's
like nothing with them you know that's
true I'm not saying there has to be like
like great romance scenes or some [__]
making out at the funeral but it's been
like a few episodes of nothing with them
really other than like oh he sees her in
a dress he like damn she look good yeah
and then they all bust his his chops
about that yeah Donald's like wow is
that something in your pants Reaching
Forward you know oh hey it's
pennis
Jack Jack Jack weener Jack
weer
Jack we we grew up P yep we grew up from
when we met yep yep yep we both
literally We Are Men We are adults we
made a genitals joke was childish were
like it's so goofy cuz they might do it
they might can't say that can't say that
word what would happen if on the show
they they did it like in the last
episode the last frame is them doing it
together just doing it uh I I like I'm
torn and I think I'm you know I'm just
sitting here waiting for the end of the
season to come because I'm like I partly
en enjoy because I hate this show I hate
everything about it and all the viewers
who tune in every week to both the show
and these reactions we shouldn't have
been middling about the second or third
episode now no one wants to watch our
videos you know anytime I have that
feeling I'm just going to be like I
assume I'll like this later so I love it
now uh
but uh I mean part of me is is enjoying
the fact that it isn't the point or it
isn't like a major focal aspect however
I I do get what you mean and I am
rooting for something to become of this
romance I think the show is in an unique
position because this first season had
such a lovely kind of thing with Rosco
but you also know that we're going to
roll out of town and onto the next thing
so you can't well I can see how Dixon
could have a relationship with him and
they could travel around together I just
think that chemistry or whatever they're
they hint at romantically or even
sexually is kind of like completely
absent unless they make like a scene
about it you know yeah totally and I
mean I I buy parts of that because
they're you know they're so professional
their unit and everything and they have
their group is
true you know how to separate it yeah
but at the same time I don't
like whenever like all of us are in the
room I forget about you and terara yes
yes we've been married for so long now
being a long-term husband and wife
couple that's right you know we like to
be professional so professional that no
one knows we're even involved with each
other sometimes you guys forget yeah and
I'm like wait Tera you can't be making
out with that guy you're married to John
you can't go out on another date you're
oh sorry I'm being professional in
public no one will know this is the best
cover possible I mean it is it is or
you're just a Brazen
cheater but you know as long as you
don't enjoy any of it then it's a good
cover Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
team I think this video is I think it
was that a while ago leave your best
Reacher puns in the comments
yeah
bye all right John pick a name oh
goodness who could it be
well you know why don't we go with Kevin
smart why just because I feel like that
would be a smart thing to do here at the
very end of our Patron list for the
month I love hearing it Kevin right now
you are our last patron of the day shout
out uh I cannot hear out of my left ear
and my right nose is my right nostril is
clogged it's a real weird ear just nose
and throat experience I'm having right
now but I am so happy to be here with
you because when I was outside I bumped
into the Hanukkah bear and oh yeah and I
don't know if you know about the
Hanukkah bear but this this Santa comes
through the chimney hanuk be goes
through your trash and hanuk be he I
don't know how he does it but hanuk be
goes all worldwide around and goes
through everyone's trash days and leaves
yeah yeah that's that's the thing is
like s 24 hours Hanukkah bear has eight
days to get it done so it's kind of a
cheat C for the Hanukkah bear and the
Hanukkah bear uh he he done left you
some great things and he but he had to
give it all to you in one day oh and so
Kevin smart what's what did he give him
John oh Kevin smart the first day of
Hanukkah bear visits he barfed up some
body parts for you to sort through I
mean those those will come in handy you
know and we are on the verge of an
apocalypse did you hear about Biden and
all them building bunkers you know that
means that they're we're on the verge of
Apocalypse pretty soon cannibalism is
going to become a normal thing so there
you go El get uh oh he he got um a PS4
that's great man PS4 they're much more
valuable you can bu you get two PS4s put
them together you got ps8 isn't that
magical dude it's so crazy and then you
can upload your Consciousness
on yeah see yeah uh oh on the third day
uh oh he he brought you a nice bowl of
Christmas punch somehow that's great man
you know Christmas punch is good to get
drunk while you're sipping on some limbs
yes definitely oh and and then the
fourth thing that the Hanukkah bear
brought you is uh uh one of those Smokey
the Bear fire risk signs so that you
could always be aware of when you are a
risk to uh you know causing a fire very
true especially in times of cannibalism
you might need to know if there's a fire
going off that way and you need to get
your sniper rifle ready and get ready to
hunt down some people might want to take
over your territory but you got to look
after your own yeah and you might want
to use that fire to cook them so if you
could you know like snipe the people as
close the fire as possible this is just
practical for planning Amen to that what
else amen eight days John he brought
you oh a new electric toothbrush cuz you
know you got to keep your teeth clean
it's always a good idea I don't need to
add on with six yeah six day uh oh he
brought you he he just took a dump on
the driveway you know Hanukkah bear he's
eating a lot of stuff and got avoid that
to keep limber believe it or not that
could be a great dessert for you and
your future family and then you you got
to spread it
Camp you're going to be a camp leader
you're going to need to spread it out
some people you know put human remains
in pies you're going to have to put bare
fees yeah seven Olive Garden gift card
of course yes that uh there will be the
one thriving restaurant in the in the
apoc can Pacos just don't eat the bread
sticks they're not like they used to be
no they're made out of bare feces yes of
course they are and uh oh the last day
uh for Hanukkah bear brought you new
trash cans because let's face it the old
ones are going to be wrecked by the time
the Hanukkah bear is done with them it's
occupational hazard so yeah man dude
Kevin Smart looks like you are going to
be living the High Life come 2024 else
got their bunkers let's recap uh you I
don't remember what the first thing is
you got body parts bared up body
parts uh it's a
PS4 uh uh some something or other an
Olive Garden gift card and and some Tonk
some
linked logs and a Tonka toy and some
tily winks and a new trash can some real
[__] in there some
poop source of [__] all righty man oh
electric toothbrush in there somewhere
yeah yeah yeah Merry Christmas so many
good things and happy Hanukkah love you
[Music]
bud